oh my gosh that is like a master
painting right there that is
unbelievable the sky this morning oh and
speaking of picks pix at 8newsnow.com
please if you're taking morning Sunrise
shots it is a photo op kind of Friday
morning please get out there take them
and send them to us so that we can share
them with other viewers and we'd love to
do that this is one of those maybe I
should just do the whole forecast
standing in front of this camera shot
it's so pretty all right let's check
Valley temperatures mostly in the 40s
but a couple of neighborhoods have
dropped to 30s Nellis at 37 Mountain's
Edge Sunrise Mountain and Seven Hills 34
out at Red Rock and we've got just
barely below freezing up at Kyle Canyon
some 30's out in Pahrump up in Mesquite
and around 40 in Boulder City 42 for the
high up on the mountain we've got
morning clouds up in the higher
elevations but then we'll get more sun
in the afternoon but Northerly breezes
are going to start blowing that's going
to be cool extra cool especially up in
the mount mountains today we'll look for
those winds maybe 15 20 25 miles an hour
and then they'll come back a little bit
in the afternoon hours for Saturday if
you're looking for outdoor plans wind
free Sunday is probably your best bet
this is just a little disturbance it's
kind of riding over the ridge of high
pressure the real big weather story
though is across the Great Lakes there
is so much snow now that it's going to
be piling up already more than a foot on
the ground in Buffalo and check this out
a backyard overnight
oh
yeah lightning strike with thunder snow
yes they were able to catch it and uh
that was a really good camera work there
by that resident in Buffalo New York but
you know that they were a little shaken
up by that that's a little scary all
right so an explosion of snow across the
Great Lakes two to four feet of snow
over the next 24 to 48 hours there all
right so high clouds this morning those
will be continuing to move South and
then we do have a wind advisory out at
Lake Mead along the Colorado River
Valley and that's in place from Friday
night tonight 6 p.m until Saturday night
6 p.m as the winds will get a little bit
stronger maybe 40 50 miles an hour in
those areas 61 for the high today so
clouds this morning mostly sunny for the
afternoon and those northeasterly
breezes today into Saturday a little
cooler for the weekend but warmer next
week into Thanksgiving we'll be grateful
for those mid to Upper 60's Thursday
into Friday